how are you guys doing good steve how
are you doing nice to see you man good
to see you uh nice to see both of you uh
i want to start with i'm sure you're
hearing this from everyone i often love
this movie like you cannot believe it is
amazing uh and again i'm sure it's a
love fest for everyone who's coming into
the room so enjoy it
and
you can nail them on the head you gotta
enjoy these
these moments come few and far between
so yeah we're soaking in every second
um so i uh
million things i would like to talk
about but dune is loaded with such
incredible stuff
that you could talk about every aspect
of this film and you know but i'm
curious when you were talking to your
friends and family what did you always
want to tell them about regarding like
the movie what were the some of the
things that just kept resonating with
you
i mean
it's it's a it's a i mean i just i felt
so grateful to be a part of it so
there's like bragging rights like
you got to see this like this is tight
and it was another thing it was because
i was only there for a brief amount of
time so i didn't get to see
all these gorgeous sets that all of you
guys had shot in before i came in and um
i was like i was blown away like i from
the script or from things that i had
seen in the book you know you have an
idea in your head or you can try to come
up with something in your head but i
think
denny has a
really spectacular way of
blowing that out of the water like
whatever you had in your head whatever
he has in his head is going to be better
than that you know um so yeah and again
the attention to detail and for those
who have read books or are true fans of
it like the the the level of care that
these
two very creative individuals took with
those characters and and
um with this story i think is also
really important because i know it means
a lot to to them so
just from the outside looking in because
i know that i'm a part of the movie but
i also feel kind of like a fan on the
outside i can say it's uh i was blown
away
yeah definitely i mean that i i've found
it rare
to talk to someone about this project
and either
and find that they're either not a fan
of the book of denise or one of back one
of the actors in the camera you know and
uh
so
um
as as in dave said i
i'm not in a braggadocio's way but i
just feel like bragging rights because
it feels like a big honor and a big
big challenge to take it on you know and
people i think like yourself have had a
connection with the material for a long
time if not the amazing david lynch
version in the 80s so
you know just to get to take it on take
on these roles
get to work with you know
zendaya javier bardem he's made this
amazing group of actors and going on
about everyone
you know a dream come true and
i could i could talk about that with
everyone i wanted to ask about it
uh this is one of those films that for
the love of god i need a sequel made
like i really need it because it's so
good and i'm curious what did you both
learn
from working with denis and about your
characters that you would be excited to
you know explore what did you learn
making this that you want to you know
what i mean if you if you were lucky
enough to make the sequel
for me don't lose the humanity and i
think there was a temptation in
understanding these archetypal you know
uh hero like characters to
you know be curious about what the
aspects of the my dear than why deeb or
coming into that power were what the
effect would be on on paul and i love
denise focus on retaining the humanity
the need for it or else
you know or else some some qualities
lost so i think that's important for me
to when i think about a potential sequel
that's something to keep in mind
um
for for me i mean
oh man it's i mean it's also one of
those things where it's like you know
the books exist so we know what's kind
of to come and it's like
it's teasing you you're like oh there's
so much more
cool things to do you know um
but i i you know i would say i i i
enjoyed like
also like getting into the physicality
of the fremen people and i think what's
really cool especially about the fight
choreography something i noticed that i
thought was so brilliant um and also in
the design of everything as well um is
that you know each
house kind of has their own very
distinct style and even their own
distinct style of fighting and moving um
whether you know depending upon what
planet you're from or you know what
house you belong to and so for me it was
uh cool to really see that distinction
um especially you know when i was there
that day i remember um
denny's saying to me you know like she
knows every way of the of the
of her planet like of the desert you
know so she's one with it and she would
move almost cat-like you know like um
with grace and and you know this this is
her home you know she doesn't know
anything else so
she's not going to be stumbling you know
as she crawls to you know crawls up a
row or a rock or a mountain or whatever
she's this is like very comfortable for
her so i had to always keep that in mind
and like kind of preset where i was
going to put my movie you know and and
try to do it in a in as smooth and as
graceful
of a way as i can um so you know just be
interested in kind of leaning more into
all those those those details and stuff
like that and i'd love to learn the
language of them from the friend of
people
so i have to go oh i was just gonna say
they're gonna kill me um listen thank
you so much for your time and congrats
and congrats on this movie for real
thank you thank you so much